Why are you now Francoise
seat orange asked,
why are,
you know,
hiding the amount you
receive from Patriot?
I found it very motivating to see the
amount skyrocket and telled glad to be
part of this as if you were an artist.
I now feel more like I'm buying a
product and I find it less appealing.
Yeah.
Well it's one of those things where I'm
kind of damned if I do and damned if I
don't,
you know,
and I don't know what's correct.
I guess I probably got tired of,
um,
the sort of more left leaning,
let's say radical left leaning press
people jumping up and down on me every
chance they got because people
were donating money for,
for services that I s particularly rent,
you know,
that I render essentially for free.
Um,
you know,
I,
there must be 10 articles in the last
week following the Lindsay Shepherd
incident pointing out that I'm
somehow being manipulative and,
and,
uh,
evil in a capitalist
sort of way for daring to
okay,
allow people to donate money
to help support what I'm doing.
And it gets kind of tiring.
And so I dunno,
I just,
and I guess I also thought that
maybe there's a part of it.
It's like,
well,
I wouldn't exactly call it bragging,
but because it's not,
but
ah,
that spoke good enough.
I mean,
it was an appeal to privacy,
I suppose,
in part two.
I Dunno if it's the right thing.
I could do a poll on Twitter and find out,
I guess I did that first.
Some other things this week.
So anyways,
that's,
that's the answer to that.